[Music]
Google Earth uses satellites and
airplanes to compile images from all
around the globe these aerial shots have
captured many of the wonders of the
world and some pretty creepy places too
we've gathered the wackiest most
shocking images that are unexplainable
and we can't take our eyes off of them
if you're new to our channel don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we'll be
sharing 10 bizarre images caught on
Google Earth that no one can explain
just wait until you see the pictures of
a Red Lake in Iraq you'll be absolutely
amazed face in clay when looking at all
the amazing aerial images on Google
Earth you probably wouldn't expect to
see a face staring right back at you but
that's exactly what happened when
someone plugged in the coordinates in
Alberta Canada and stumbled upon this
intriguing monument it is now called the
Badlands guardian and if you look
closely you can make out the face of a
human head but it's not just any human
head it actually appears to be a Native
American man you can clearly make out
the shape of his eyes his nose his lips
and his chin he also appears to be
wearing a feathered headdress the
monument is located in a valley full of
eroded play and many suspect as a
leftover artifact from many years ago
others believe it's just a coincidence
that the clay took on the shape of a
human face so what do you believe do you
think this could actually be a clay
sculpture created by a Native American
tribe many years ago Gobi Desert you
won't believe what Google Earth
satellite images captured in China the
image was spotted in the Gobi Desert a
vast area with many isolated stretches
of land this photo was literally taken
out in the middle of nowhere but as you
can see there's something strange going
on these structures with reflective
lines can be seen from space another
nearby area shows intricately designed
circles on the ground and three Jets
parked in the middle of the circle this
piece of land is 70 miles out from the
nearest main road so the structures were
definitely constructed out in the middle
of nowhere for a reason the
grids and circular areas stretch for
miles and miles and they are less than
100 miles from China's space program
many believe this area is a top-secret
location for the Chinese military and
potentially an area for nuclear and
missile testing we'll probably never
know what really goes on in the middle
of the Gobi Desert but at least we can
keep an eye on this area through Google
Earth wouldn't it be cool if this plot
of land had something to do with
extraterrestrials and UFOs giant crop
circles crop circles have been one of
the Earth's greatest mysteries many
believe they have been around for
centuries potentially dating way back to
the 1600s they range from simple circles
to really fancy and intricate designs
many crop circles have been proven to be
hoaxes and some people actually create
them for a living or just for fun but
there are a few giant ones located
around the world that have yet to be
explained to this day this one which is
located in the Netherlands is one of the
most popular sites on Google Earth no
one is sure about where it came from or
how it got there but it truly is a sight
to be seen
many people have created their own
theories on how this design was created
and some even think it's related to
extraterrestrial activities many
conspiracy theorists think that only
something that's out of this world could
create a perfectly geometric pattern
just like this we may never know where
this particular crop circle came from or
who made it but it's fun to come up with
theories on how it originated don't you
agree
where do you think crop circles come
from area 6 using Google Earth you can
pull up this amazing and intriguing
image of area 6 this is a secluded
secret region in the remote Nevada
desert located 65 miles from the bright
lights of Las Vegas this area is
controlled by the American government it
was initially established as an airbase
unless you have the correct credentials
you'll never be able to enter area 6
it's fenced off from miles away and
you're not even allowed to fly a plane
or helicopter above it without military
clearance that's why so many of us are
intrigued by this location and it's one
of the first places many people plug in
when they first use Google
earth since this is a classified
location protected by the United States
government
there isn't much known about what really
goes on behind its doors we know that
some nuclear testing has taken place but
that's about it in the image of Google
Earth you can see a cluster of buildings
and a really long runway for military
planes to take off and land security
experts believe this location is the
home to a top-secret fleet of drones but
we'll probably never know its true
purpose giant pentacle what you see here
is one of the creepiest images ever
spotted on Google Earth this pentacle is
1,200 feet wide and it's located in a
remote area of Asia that was formerly a
part of the Soviet Union it's right on
the southern shore of a reservoir and it
can be found more than 12 miles from the
nearest city and miles away from
civilization
Pentacles are usually associated with
all things dark spooky and evil it's
also a symbol that's commonly used in
black magic and the occult so it really
makes us wonder how and why this
pentacle ended up on this plot of land
scientists were even scratching their
heads when they first saw this bizarre
phenomenon when the pentacle was first
discovered by Google Earth users they
were able to zoom in on the image two
locations one called Adam and the other
called Lucifer would pop up on the
screen this really had people convinced
that this particular area was linked to
some dark and shady activity after the
media had spread the news about the
strange pentacle Google Earth disabled
the zoom feature on the image and
magically the two locations in Adam and
Lucifer mysteriously disappeared what do
you think goes on in this remote area in
Asia don't forget to leave your answer
down below in the comment section UFO
landing area doesn't this picture look
like something that was drawn on a
chalkboard well it's actually an image
that was pulled from Google Earth this
place exists in real life but no one's
quite sure about what takes place here
we know that it's a military base
outside of Norwich England and a UK
Ministry of Defence has it classified as
a motorcycle range but of course no one
believes this to be true without further
confirmation from the military on what
this area is truly used for people are
left to speculate on this aerial
shot of the piece of land it looks like
a bunch of different lines and squiggles
there's also a couple of rectangles and
dashes down the center that look a lot
like the lines found on most roads some
people have suspected that this area
could be a collaboration device for out
of space satellites and others think
it's used as a landing pad for UFOs we
could probably come up with a million
theories on what this area is used for
how about you do you think these
geometric lines and shapes could really
be the center of a landing pad for UFOs
Russia's diamond mine take a look at
this Google Earth image it may look like
a giant sinkhole or maybe even a huge
swimming pool in the middle of the city
but this huge hole has a completely
different purpose it's located in Russia
and it's an open diamond mine that was
constructed by the former Soviet leader
Joseph Stalin dating back to the 1960s
this 4,000 foot long line produced 10
million carats worth of diamonds in one
year having a mind that's more than
1,700 feet deep in the middle of the
city makes for a beautiful and stunning
image on Google Earth but for those who
work in the area there's nothing
beautiful about this site the open
diamond mine is located around
restricted airspace any helicopter that
chooses to ignore the warnings has the
potential to get sucked into its
spiraling vortex winter lasts for up to
10 months a year and temperatures can
get as low as negative 40 degrees
Celsius operations at the mine stopped
in 2001 but they resumed mining at a new
area that's underneath the original
gaping hole to get to the location
workers must use a truck to slowly drive
down the mines dangerous spirals
there isn't much known about what really
goes on behind its doors a rocks Red
Lake this looks pretty creepy don't you
think when playing around on Google
Earth some users spotted this Lake back
in 2007 that looked completely out of
place it's very noticeable because it
sits right next to other lakes that
appear to be of a normal color if you
plug in some specific coordinates Google
Earth will bring up this body of water
that looks red from the satellite shot
many people were freaked out because
they believe the water was full of
but researchers have put that rumor to
rest because it would be impossible to
dump enough blood to turn the entire
lake red so what gives well other people
believe the lake is red due to sewage a
water treatment process or pollution
others think increasing levels of salt
water have given this lake its bloody
red colors so as you can see there are
so many theories but just not enough
answers would you love to see this red
Lake in person and if so what do you
think really caused it to get its red
colour man-shaped lake using Google
Earth you can view lakes of all shapes
colors and sizes most of them look quite
similar they're all large bodies of
water and some are surrounded by trees
and other vegetation when people set out
to use Google Earth for the first time
pulling up the coordinates of a lake
usually isn't the first thing on their
to-do list there are so many other
amazing sites to be viewed and lakes
aren't as exciting as other locations
like viewing the Pyramids of Egypt but
this is one lake that you might want to
check out the next time you're using the
virtual program it's located near the
Brazilian city of Sao Paulo but there's
something really different about this
body of water as you can see it's in the
shape of a man and it's located in a
heavily wooded area researchers have
estimated that this man shaped Lake is
about 500 feet long but that's all
that's really known about it what do you
think the story is behind this lake let
us know your thoughts down below in the
comment section
we can't wait to read your reply hot
spring how beautiful is this colorful
image from Google Earth the vibrant hues
are absolutely breathtaking but the
story behind this picture is even more
fascinating you're looking at a Google
Earth capture of the Grand Prismatic hot
spring of Yellowstone National Park in
Wyoming this brightly colored spring of
water is over 121 feet deep and 370 feet
wide hot water from a crack in the earth
travels to the surface of the spring and
can reach temperatures as high as 189
degrees Fahrenheit in photos taken on
land
you can even see the heat rising from
the middle of the body of water so how
does this spring get it's beautiful
vibrant yellow color
that surrounds it well the yellow color
is the result of different species of
heat-loving bacteria that live around
the outer edge of the spring but Google
Earth satellites can't pick up all of
its rings of color there are actually
other shades like orange and burgundy
too if you're not able to see the hot
springs in real life taking a visit to
Google Earth is the next best option you
can view this natural wonder of the
world from the comforts of your own home
which of these images from Google Earth
shocked you the most react in the
comments section and please don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up
thanks for watching
[Music]